Fox News Alert Jesse is back at the
table his wife Emma gave birth to his
gorgeous New Daughter Georgina post
Waters Georgina or Gigi as we are
calling her I'm not sure how to spell it
though makes Jesse a girl dad times
three good thing he's wearing this suit
who knows what could be on that after
all the baby holding that he's been
doing the past couple of weeks Jesse is
happy to take a break from changing
those dirty diapers but being a new dad
is tough we have some video of Jesse
going over the show with the producers
what is the best way to disseminate
important information in an efficient
way
that's uh Jesse's twins Ellie and Sophie
are very excited to have a little sister
and looks like Jesse Jr is already
chipping in
I think that's enough Jess
nope that's good she's got a lot of
goldfish
very good sharing
rookie yeah good sharing Jess that was
really nice
[Music]
one more and then we're done
oops you missed all right one more
give her one more
nice good job high five
awesome wow he's really I mean giving up
goldfish is a big deal Jesse what's it
like now that you have little Gigi in
your life it's great I'm not that tired
we have a big we have a baby nurse Greg
doesn't even know what a baby nurse is
she just asked me what's a baby nurse so
that's Gigi a little controversy I've
been spelling the girl's name wrong okay
is it
g-i-g-i or is it capital G lowercase i
capital G lowercase i you have to tell
us I don't know
I don't know she knows either of course
she lower cases so wait does a baby
nurse you just sleep then yeah yeah so
the baby nurse does the nights right so
we can get some rest this is incredible
so the irony is you have a baby and
we're the ones tuckered out
so to speak very good you've had a tough
Savage yeah you didn't miss anything
trust me but when you do the handoff
tonight check the monitor
I shouldn't wing it yeah don't wing it
all right I'll see what I can do and
it's been a really great two weeks I
thought about extending my paternity I'm
legally entitled to six weeks so I
didn't actually have to come back today
so why did you choose two because I
missed you judge I don't believe them
isn't it weird that it's called GG it
I'm sorry she's called GG it's not about
you but I'm just saying I'm just saying
think about this that this is perhaps a
sign from above that somebody should be
the Godfather in this room
uh and it might be Gigi I was thinking
it's because you guys are almost the
same size yes that's why it's so funny
the first day we announced that Emma was
pregnant with with we didn't have the
name yet you mentioned George Foreman
and you mentioned the fact that George
Foreman that's had an ego and named all
of his children after himself and you
said Georgina exactly and we just so
happened to name her Georgina wow that
is creepy look how tiny she is yeah
she's very small there yeah that she was
six three yeah I believe at Birth then
they lose weight they actually lose
weight in the hospital I bet you didn't
know that you put it on ozepik
yeah we had the IV with the ozempic and
and then she gains it back uh because of
all of the bottles we don't know what
we're feeding what about you sucking it
down transition go he's fine don't
transition him he's still identifying as
male but he's been a great older brother
I've spent a lot of time with him which
has been great because usually I just
ignore him and prep for the five right
yeah you're laughing are you laughing
that I prep for the five or did I ignore
him very funny girl how did you guys
arrive on post as the middle name which
is beautiful post is a family name on
Emma's side great grandmother and it
just flows really well Georgina post
Waters we were thinking about Emma Jr
that was my suggestion or Jessica right
but we went with Georgina post what is
post it's a family name you weren't
listening I wasn't that Messiah wait you
already covered that yeah
do you feel that there have been changes
in your cortex because I've been reading
about neuroplasticity that your brain
changes and grows when you develop a new
skill taking care of a baby for example
well I don't know if you could measure
my brain growing there's there's a lot
of room it's hard to tell I don't have
baby brain I think the women get the
baby brain right no but the best did the
men get the baby the package
I was changing diapers I've actually
changed two diapers see that's the thing
with having a nurse or the nurses at the
hospital when the baby goes to the
bathroom and the nurse is there you kind
of want to give the nurse a look like
maybe could you get this one yeah but
you also don't want to look like a bad
father and so you kind of are guilted
into changing the diaper so I've changed
a few well you're a winning hearts and
Minds all across America
I am I have changed diapers it's just
like Dr Jill
I
baby in the car seat do you guys
struggle or you're a pro now I I
actually had to have Emma's mother
install the car seat in the car because
I couldn't figure it out I got
frustrated and walked away but now it's
fine and she's in the car seat all right
so now what about the dog the dog is
still there the dog was fine in the
beginning and then a dog got Rowdy and
started eating everything so we gave the
dog to Emma's parents and the dog's been
there the last four nights for how long
will the dog be gone until it stops
raining so much
now rookie will reunite soon with the
family we just don't know when but it's
been chaos so how long does the baby
sleep at night I don't know because I'm
sleeping oh but the baby's been sleeping
pretty well we think I've been told all
right so the baby nurse is happy that's
what you're saying the baby nurse is
great we love Judith uh she introduced
us to a show I've never seen before
Family Feud have you seen Kim oh yes
with Steve Harvey yes that's never never
seen it
Greg and I always wanted the five to go
against the view for charity I love that
that's a great idea it's a great show we
would crush them yes we would you're
telling me you just heard of Family Feud
I've just watched family watch Family
Feud I don't watch TV
yeah I like Family Feud it's a good show
except some of the answers by these
family members are ridiculous but that's
what makes it so funny and then Steve
Harvey's reaction to these crazy family
members is gold when I get fired from
Fox I want to host Family Feud
a question that is like bigger picture
just like for people out there who are
thinking about either you know
committing and getting married and
having a family and becoming a dad and
being a part of a bigger think something
bigger than yourself and being the head
of the family like
a little bit of a big thought something
I'm serious I don't know I mean you
don't have to be serious with baby brain
here
it was really nice these last two weeks
with paternity because you spend a lot
of quality time with the family good
one-on-one time with the sun I did
change More Diapers than I'm giving
myself credit for and Emma has just been
spectacular she's lost almost all of the
babies I saw a picture she looks good
she looks absolutely incredible we don't
think she's human
we're sending her to hospitals for tests
but it's been great and now I'm a father
of four
um so I have a lot of weddings three to
pay for
and that's why I can't get fired from
Fox because there's these weddings are a
lot of money you just keep holding my
hand and we will see if we can keep you
here with us we want you here with us
and we are glad that you're back coming
up under Biden in court for a child
support battle that could expose how he
makes his money hi everyone I'm Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now